[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an episode called the
many place from the anthology horror
television series creeped out
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the blowlizens family has come to north
queensland australia to enjoy their
summer vacation they are staying at a
five-star hotel called ashgrove however
they are welcomed by heavy rainfall
thanks to the place's tropical climate
as the parents complain about the
weather the receptionist tells them
about all the different activities they
can do in the hotel without having to go
outdoors the eldest daughter of the
family nita locks eyes with a teenage
boy in the lobby they exchange numbers
and decide to meet at the swimming pool
later the youngest of the family max
runs inside the elevator and presses all
the buttons just for the fun of it she
is stopped by the hotel's boilerman he
has worked in the hotel for several
years and knows all of its secrets the
man warns max against pressing all the
buttons claiming that bad things happen
to kids who do so he also mentions
someone named quinken but before he can
elaborate the hotel clerk approaches
them she reminds him that the elevator
is only for guests and he isn't allowed
to use it the boilerman curses her and
walks away leaving max speechless after
the encounter the clerk uses her keys to
reset the buttons on the elevator and
brings the family to their room they are
staying in a single room hence the kids
fight about who gets to use the bathroom
first nita accidentally scrapes max's
favorite black sandals in the process
the sisters used to be best friends but
now that nida is growing into a teenager
they have grown apart max asks her
father if she will also grow up to
become like her sister the father
understands that she is hurt by anita's
behavior and consoles her the parents
want some free time from the children so
they send them off to the hotel's pool
nita had planned to meet the guy from
earlier and doesn't want to take her
siblings but at her parents request she
reluctantly brings them along the middle
child jed loves to play video games he
walks through the hallways while wearing
a virtual reality headset and
accidentally bumps into a table dropping
a framed picture he puts it back upside
down before entering the elevator with
his sisters as usual max presses all the
buttons in the elevator saying that the
lights look pretty this time they do not
have a key to reset it all of a sudden
the elevator shakes aggressively and
starts moving when it stops nita tries
to press other buttons but none of them
work they blame max for being careless
and to decide to take the stairs the
hallways look different to them but the
kids do not think much of it jett also
notices that the floor feels cold in
contrast to how it was some moments ago
they go around the hallways looking for
stairs but cannot find any the elevator
that they came through is lost and they
have no way to return to their parents
even the rooms have no numbers which max
thinks is weird nita tries calling her
parents but her phone has no signal they
knock on one of the doors to ask for
help and find that it is already open
but inside the door lies another hallway
that is identical to the one they are in
right now they check other doors and
find out that they are stuck in a
maze-like place where every door leads
to a different identical hallway the
younger siblings start to panic but nita
calms them down she claims that all they
have to do is find the elevator again
and return to their parents suddenly
they hear a loud growl from behind a
door max claims that the noise is coming
from quinken who the boilerman warned
her about as the growling gets louder
she starts to panic and hyperventilates
nita asks her to breathe and plays their
favorite bobo ski game to calm her down
but trouble arises when they hear a
faint snarling getting closer on looking
under a door they see a pair of
monster's feet on the other side they
screech in fear and run through random
doors getting further away from their
original elevator in the process max
runs faster than the other two and gets
lost nita and jett try calling her but
she has run down several hallways and
cannot hear them when max stops running
she calls for her siblings and realizes
that she has lost them while looking for
her jett and nita hear an elevator door
ding followed by melodic music they
follow the sound and finally reach the
elevator nita doesn't want to leave
without max but jett claims that if they
inform their parents they will find her
quicker they get on the elevator and jet
notices the red interior when he clearly
remembers it being a neutral color
before the elevator shakes as it did
earlier making them think that they will
end up back in the maze however this
time they reach back to their floor in
the hotel when they passed the hallway
we noticed that the framed picture that
was upside down earlier is now back in
its correct position nida uses the keys
to open the door to their room however
they are met with a surprise when they
see two strangers inside when asked what
they are doing there the strangers claim
that they have been in the room for a
week the kids then go to the reception
and inquire about their parents the
clerk who checked them in only a few
hours ago claims that no one of that
name are staying at the hotel the
boilerman overhears their conversation
and seems to know the truth about the
maze back in the hallways max is trying
to look for her siblings she hears a
roar and curls up on the floor crying in
fear suddenly someone runs towards her
on looking at the person's face max
freezes in shock somewhere else nida and
jett are confused out of their minds
nita googles her mother's name and finds
out her number the mother picks up the
call from her workplace in the other
part of the world when nita tries to
explain what happened she stops her and
asks her who she is it turns out that
the mother is living an entirely
different life and has a boyfriend who
is not their father she insists that she
isn't married and has no kids and cuts
the phone call the siblings are left
speechless at their mother's
indifference as they brainstorm ideas to
get out of the situation the boilerman
approaches them he asks them if they
pressed all the buttons in the elevator
and calls them out for being idiots he
also explains that the hallway they
reached after pressing the buttons is
called the many place it is a cluster of
pathways to alternate universes a place
where all the realities meet when the
kids look at him in confusion he further
explains that their universe is one of
many universes that exist in space each
universe gives birth to the same people
but with different realities like their
mother who is married and has children
in one reality but is a working woman
with a boyfriend in another the many
place looks like a maze at first glance
but the doors aren't as random as they
seem each door leads them closer to an
elevator that is the path to an
alternate reality there are a billion of
them and hence to find the one they came
from will require a lot of work he
suggests they retrace their steps
through the doors and find the original
elevator that they came from at last he
also warns them that looking for the
original elevator is not that easy as he
has never met someone who found their
way back after getting lost jett looks
out the window and sees flying cars that
are considered usual in this reality the
brother and sister go back to the
elevator when the boilerman stops them
he adds that the many place was built as
a way to punish the humans who had
committed unfathomable crimes the place
they are going to has a cruel creature
who eats lost people hence the children
should be careful if they want to safely
reach their original elevator following
the encounter they press all the buttons
and end up back in the mini place after
looking around for more than an hour
they finally find another lift however
on reaching the hotel they immediately
find out that they are not in their
original reality the place is filled
with smoke and the sound of missiles
launching can be heard from outside it
is clear that in this reality the world
is at war they return to the many place
and start looking for another elevator
after a few more hours they finally find
another one but it is filled with water
denoting that the world is underwater in
that reality on their third elevator
ride they reach an abandoned hotel and
lose hope of finding their original
reality nita breaks down crying
realizing that she will never meet her
parents and her sister again when jett
tries to comfort her she tells him that
they cannot go down billions of
different elevators jet on the other
hand asks her to pull it together
because she is supposed to be an adult
with renewed motivation they collect
things they might need to navigate
through the maze they decide that
finding max is more important than
finding their original reality because
she might be scared and lonely nida gets
a horn some pencils and a stick to fight
the creature they had seen earlier
following that they enter the many place
and mark all the doors that they've
walked through they call max using the
horn and quickly cross many hallways but
even after hours of searching they do
not find her all of a sudden they hear
max's voice calling to them she is just
around the corner but she asks them to
not come near her when the siblings
throw several questions at her she asks
them to just trust her she also urges
them to keep their eyes closed at all
costs because she has someone else with
her who is helping her navigate when
they are finally face to face max
reveals that the creature behind her is
quinken the monster that the boilerman
had warned them about quincan cannot
help but to eat the eyes of people who
look at him hence they should keep their
eyes closed apart from that he is a
gentle creature who has lived in the
many place his entire life he knows
every corner of the place and wants to
help them get back to their original
reality max and need a hug while still
keeping their eyes closed they trust
quinken and hold his hand after that
they slowly make their way to the
elevator and start it as the doors close
they open their eyes and get a glimpse
of quincun's gruesome face thankfully
the door's shut before he can attack and
the kids are brought back to their
original reality they see that the
framed picture is upside down and
finally sigh with relief while walking
back to the room nida asks max how she
found out that they should close their
eyes max mentions the boilerman and says
that he is blind nida stops her and
inquires what that means then she
notices that max isn't wearing her
favorite black sandals that she was
wearing when they first entered the
elevator max also mentions their
grandmother and claims that she is dead
soon nita realizes that they picked up
max from a different reality who is lost
in the same maze as them she is not the
girl they grew up with but is from a
parallel universe when they reach their
room the group is beyond surprised to
see that the real max is already there
she is trying to explain everything to
her parents who clearly don't believe
her that is until they get a look at
their daughter's doppelganger and freeze
in shock the movie ends as the real max
begs her parents to keep the other max
as their fourth daughter
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching